this is the spider tortoise  these little guys are so endangered that  scientists say that they could  completely vanish in the next 15 years  the spider tortoise is hard to find  for one they're tiny  one of the smallest known land turtles  rarely reaching more than six inches in  length  another reason they only inhabit a tiny  sliver of madagascar's southwestern  coast  their name comes from the web-like  patterns on their shelves  during the dry season they bury  themselves in the sand and re-emerge  when it rains to feed on leaves roots  and insects  just because they're tiny doesn't mean  they're young they're estimated to live  up to 70 years in the wild  these little guys are up against a lot  the largest concern is that they are  still hunted locally for food but the  illegal pet trade and shrinking habitat  are all threats to their survival this  is the spider tortoise